je m'appelle malak j'ai 25 ans je suis
égyptienne motifs de ce continent
le scope daniël anglaise pouvons à
l'exemple du tout je n'aurais jamais
imaginé que dix ans plus tard
tout s'est enthousiasmé cet optimiste
qu'on avait serait en vain
[Musique]
c'était il ya dix ans un air de révolte
s'empare du monde arabe dans la rue les
dégage résonne aux oreilles des régimes
autoritaires en première ligne c'est la
jeunesse qui porte la révolution où song
book of blood diamond situation pour le
teckel aux commandes que l'autre et s'il
fallait tout recommencer
c'est la question que se posent malak
ébène peu qu'ils en 2011 assisté à la
chute de moubarak
je me souviens des jours qui ont précédé
la révolution du 25 janvier 2011 par les
deux manifestations qui ont eu lieu en
tunisie et aux usa je vois pas tous les
swing aux dates boys roue offre trop et
puis il ya eu quelques incidents
l'egypte donne qu'un attentat qui a eu
lieu à alexandrie la foule dans l'est de
bagdad et puis quelques jours plus tard
j'ai lu des publications sur facebook y
appelait les gens avaient hésité à se
rassembler par milliers le 25 janvier
même facebook et des politiques
quand j'ai raconté ça à ma mère que je
lui ai dit qu'il y aurait une révolution
du 25 janvier
le pas pris au sérieux et c'est pourquoi
le qwest 1/2 shaun white
shooting tous les cadets france at least
dire moi j'étais super contente pas du
tout le monde était content on était
très enthousiaste très très optimiste
quoi tout le monde voulait y participer
moi qui habitait sur une rue principale
d'alexandrie je pouvais tout voir tout
entendre tout sentir quoi surtout
lacrymogènes fiennes
à scaletta de coller et baron de police
sur la brûlante être que tu les connais
tu dis là on va situer
outre l'aide tout et continuity of the
revolution in 2006 and british airways
aux canaries
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc
bon
[Musique]
une partie des ventes de 16 ans jeune
homme possède désormais six douzaines
aux actions à bedford catherine un des
lives dette
shenzhou d'euros d'actions afin de
renforcer le rôle des jeunes et des
réseaux sociaux étaient très signifiants
je me souviens que deux jours plus tard
on a tous perdus a accès à facebook et à
twitter et qu'on pouvait même pas
envoyer de sms
mais ça n'a pas changé grand chose mais
à dimension québec qui gonfle ans kevin
gourdon et wendy ex-présidente move aux
lèvres aw oui ils sont rapides groupe
cet optimisme la a engendré un sentiment
d'appartenance l'egypte chez tout le
monde
chacun voulait faire quelque chose pour
son pays donc il y avait quelques uns
qui nettoyaient les rues ou peut on
aller parfois contre des murs et des
trottoirs en plantent des arbres sont
mes news dépendant
clint eastwood 5 millions mais simply
beauty choi dette
we want pendant la révolution il y avait
une chanson qui disait dans toutes les
rues de mon pays la voie de la liberté
appel mais il ya quatre ans on en a
refait une autre version en disant il
n'y a pas eu de révolution dans
l'enseigné en réalité les re était déjà
cinq ans
oh
mais non oh là là j'ai vraiment pas
envie de dire ça mais je trouve vraiment
que ça n'a pas changé grand chose
we will est pour la ta chance ou le
daily star du net où d'intégrité people
est devenu de plus en plus strictes
il ya moins de liberté de crottes que ça
leur compte soit très peu de nous et al
ittihad date sans people à des dommages
en dehors sans fo se sont plaintes que
force est de la gender des big three
d'antibes et rideau sarthe
on peut célébrer l'occasion de l'ancien
une révolution de 1952 mais pas celle de
on a tendance à l'oublier on veut
oublier qu'il ya une révolution c'est
pour ne pas être déçu de news of the
world is our house loft chinois de 200 t
go
reuters enfin gaz et ingenico ou juste
éleveurs du tchad où il est d'élever
seul ou jeunes ont reçu le prix red sun
and that we trust dans les troubles et
maurice solution
[Musique]